i don't think i i don't i still don't
think i am conservative in the older
meaning of the word um i'm definitely
not
you know if you went and read some
particular
you know political treatise on
conservatism i'm going to disagree with
quite a bit of it
at the same time i find a lot of
sympathy for
the arguments of preserving something
that is worth
preserving or conserving that so yeah i
was definitely not a radical definitely
kind of
middle of the road average every day
liberal left kind of guy and
i was i was genuinely like you said
apprehensive it is a kind of an
understatement to work with
conservatives in a significant
regard which has been really an
interesting experience because
they're exactly the opposite of what the
leftist propaganda had told me they
would be like
i'm dave rubin joining me today is the
founder of new discourses
and the co-author of cynical theories
how
activist scholarship made everything
about race
gender and identity james lindsay
welcome back to the reuben report
hey dave good to see you man it's good
to see you you know i didn't realize
until we booked you for today
that you've been on the show a couple
times but only in panel form
you've never been on as a as a solo
entity
this is as good as it gets huh yeah well
here i am
let's change that here you are so
actually the first time that i had you
on i had
you on with our friend peter bogosian
who uh who everybody knows and
and when the show ended that was
probably about it's got to be a good
three years already
or so and when the show ended i think
you sort of still
thought you could maybe modify some of
this stuff from within the left and i
had kind of shifted a little bit and
when the cameras went off i said well
you know james i sense that the
conservatives are going to start liking
you and you might want to go in that
direction a little bit because i think
you're going to find fertile ground for
these ideas
and i sensed you kind of were like ah i
don't want to do that just yet
that's three years ago and man it's been
a wild ride huh
yeah it's been uh been been quite the
few years um
you were very largely right about that
analysis
this interview is over that's all i
needed to hear from you there you go
dave rubin was right
you know put it on your book yeah so all
right
i didn't need the you were right but i
think you know really though but but it
does
illustrate a certain something so before
we even
go into that part of it about sort of
looking to the right for new bridges
when did you get interested in all of
this you you seem to be the main
guy covering critical race theory you've
been warning about it forever you're
taking the heat
for doing so when did this even get on
your radar
you know it hit my radar is very
interesting i didn't know what i was
looking at
obviously seven or eight years ago but i
i got involved in a conversation with a
number of people
the conversation was about a topic that
nobody finds controversial whatsoever
affirmative action
and um we're i was talking with a
blue-collar friend of mine
and he's talking about his experience
and the
probably well-founded suspicion that his
boss
was a diversity hire as opposed to
somebody who was actually
qualified and in fact was talking about
how there had been some incidents
where you know people have been put
physically at risk since he actually
works in a factory
and there were a number of other people
and if memory serves a
younger white woman was present as well
and she pointed out
you know that um there was no need to
tell this story
because white men's stories have been
told
and i kind of interjected and i said now
hold on
you know i get where you're coming from
historically
however we're in a new circumstance now
and he's trying to tell his actual
experience with what he's dealing with
and so the idea that you know white
working-class
people are going to be put underneath
the dominion of possibly
incompetent bosses that were hired for
affirmative action or diversity
reasons is a new story and we should be
telling that story and hearing that
story and seeing what there is to get to
the best
possible result and it was just like ice
his story has already been told
and i was like this is there's something
bad wrong
in that attitude that was the very first
kind of tip of the iceberg and then as
you know we were involved in the new
atheist movement
peter and i and our heroes who were
friends
previously i think with both of us who
largely don't like us anymore
were getting accused of things like
sexism and sometimes racism for
for charges that didn't make any sense
and that's where i started to hear these
words systemic racism systemic sexism
and to start to connect that to certain
stories
aren't allowed to be told whereas other
stories have to be amplified or centered
or whatever and that's where i really
started to get
concerned and nervous about this as
early as 2000 probably 14
at the latest peter and i started to
talk about it
then really so you and pete were ahead
on this
and then when did when were you like
okay well i can i either want to make a
living
dissecting this or i'm going to write a
book about this or i need to
you know this isn't a fun thing for
anyone to be involved in at a certain
level especially the way
you're involved in on it because you're
always going to be accused of being the
worst things
at all times when did you make that
shift yeah so
peter and i decided faithfully in early
2017 to write
a hoax paper targeting gender studies as
we've discussed
and we wrote the conceptual penis as a
social construct
that was its own little scandal um but
we spiked a football i don't think we
had a right to spike
we said we proved gender studies as
bogus i don't think we actually had the
evidence for that given the
poor quality of the journal that
accepted it and this created some
controversy so peter and i being peter
and i talked about it and we decided
maybe we should write more papers
and so we recruited helen faithfully and
we
set up set out on writing the papers of
the grievance studies affair
and that's where by the end of the year
2017
well into that project you know we're
actually reading their literature in
detail we're not just trying to pull
jokes by that point
we're getting feedback from academic
journals saying these are the things
that you've written for example like
this idea that you have to
kind of abuse students in the name of
progressive ideology under a progressive
stack
with experiential reparations is like
the mistake they told us that we made
they said why fragility is the right
idea but the mistake you've made is
centering compassion
you have to center discomfort otherwise
you might
refocus on or recenter the needs of the
privileged
and that's where i remember getting that
feedback and and looking at this and
thinking this like pulling back a tarp
and finding a dead body like something
really bad is happening here and as i've
gone
on and i've read more of their
literature over the years especially
when i first read a book called is
everyone really equal
um in probably the middle early part of
2019 which is written by
aslam sensoi and robin d'angelo it's an
education book written in 2012.
now it's like wow this isn't a dead body
under a tarp it's a mass grave
and at that point it's like okay i have
to basically dedicate
most of my time and energy to exposing
this
it's not about making money in fact i
didn't make any money for a long time my
wife actually literally supported us
completely because she also saw
how important it was to some for
somebody to research this and speak up
about it
to say you know something is badly off
the rails that these ideas exist isn't
itself a problem but that they're
institutionalizing is a
big problem that they're capturing a
political party
is a big problem and so i didn't make
any money for a very long time actually
working on this and
i started to research and i noticed how
often they use the words revolution
equity is not enough this is in a
mathematics education paper
maybe maybe equity isn't enough maybe
what we need is a revolution
and i thought something really bad is at
the end of this rainbow
and that's where it's everything that's
all i do
now is something really bad is the end
of this rainbow let's stop it
yeah that's why i think your your story
is so interesting because it seems like
you just kept
peeling the onion and and it kept going
deeper and deeper and getting
in some ways more perverse i mean for
the people that didn't see the episode
that i did with you and
pete in studio where you talk about the
social hoax i mean in essence what
you're saying is
you wrote something to be nonsensical
and yet it wasn't even nonsensical
enough
that that's the the really bizarre part
of of the whole thing right i mean you
couldn't
you tried to make up as nonsensical
thing as you could
yeah and that was the thing we i mean it
was one of the things that clued us in
that there was a problem and it wasn't
like finding a dead body so much as it
was
you know something's bad bad off with
academia
is that every time we'd write a paper
and we're all proud of ourselves for how
ridiculous or horrifying or whatever it
happened to be
we would find something in the existing
literature that actually already went
further
like we wrote one paper arguing that the
real reason
that men participate in combat sports
like brazilian jiu jitsu
was because secretly their society is
repressing their secret
homosexual urges and so they have to
put those forth in a in a reasonable you
know a male
acceptable way so they have to beat each
other up and that's the only way they
can possibly express their desire to hug
on and
wrestle with other men and get that
touch and we wrote this and then i found
i'm looking for
citations and i find this paper that
it's like no all competitive sports
right by a guy and the guy's name is
brian pronger it's written in like 1999
or something and the title of the paper
it's just
so absurd was you know out of my end
zone and it's basically talking about
how football teams are
all arranged around the idea of
basically having the opportunity for men
to engage in socialize like
the name of the gay porn frankly it is i
was like
i mean that made for a lot of fun for us
of course you know we end up tying my
paper you know um
uh in through the back door for example
you know about sex toys and all of this
so
i mean it opened up a lot of doors for
fun but it's like every paper we tried
to write
was there's already something that took
it further we said this one sport and
they said no all sports
and can you just explain for the people
that didn't see that interview and again
we'll link to it down below so people
can
really get an hour on the on the entire
paper hoax that you guys did
but can you just explain the mind comp
piece of this thing because i think that
if people aren't getting how absurd this
all was
that pretty much puts the nail in the
coffin yeah especially in light of the
papers that have come out recently you
know where they're
comparing whiteness to a parasitical
ideology of
dominion and whatever it's like yeah so
we
were we we had this idea that it would
be brilliant to take some horrible thing
from the history and just rewrite it
as intersectional feminism or whatever
and so
it struck eventually that you know what
is kind of this you know the iconic
horrible thing of history is on mineconf
so let's look through hitler's
autobiography and political manifesto
and see if we can find anything
so i'm reading this book for the first
time in my life and it's
shockingly bad in all regards and you
know you read chapters
one through whatever and it's him
whining about his life and then he gets
you know
well here's all my enemies and he's
railing on the communists and he's
eventually chapter 11 he's railing on
the jews and then chapter 12 i turn the
page chapter 12 it's like we need a
movement
you know here's the answer we need a
movement and i'm reading this chapter 12
and i'm like wow that's
very useful i can use this and so we
took out the word our movement he didn't
call it nazis at the time he called it
our movement
in the book and we took out the words
our movement and i just replaced it with
intersectional feminism literally just
find and replace
on like word or whatever and then it was
like okay now i read through it and i
changed the sentences so that they're
not complete nonsense that since we
changed words
and then it was like you know layers of
let's work in some research let's work
in a little bit of
you know citations let's pull from bell
hooks let's pull from these
angry feminists and we came up with this
idea that
there's a type of feminism called choice
feminism that women
enacting their own free choices is
inherently feministic
that is something they actually hate the
intersectionalists hate this
freedom of choice they're not big on
freedom of choice so that's not real
feminism
that's selling out solidarity so the
whole thing became which is what hitler
was
asking for in that chapter because he's
got like you know you have to get rid of
all of your you have to subordinate your
will no half measures blah blah blah
you know and all for solidarity to our
movement so it's like so we just rewrote
this thing as intersectional feminism
we thought there's no way anybody's
going to take
rewritten hitler as feminism we sent it
off to a journal a feminist
theory journal and they peer-reviewed it
which shocked us
and they sent back some suggestions to
improve it so we improved it
we sent it off to another journal
because they did not accept it it was a
feminist social work journal
and they did accept it they did accept a
rewrite
of hitler's solution to his political
enemies
in solidarity as uh and we kept you know
his bad mood
is we'll just call it a bad mood we kept
that there
yeah very bad mood um we kept that that
that grievance the anger in and wrote
this
railing on women who believe that making
free choices
represents the goal of feminism and that
they're
selling out their black sisters for
example and
it was accepted by a social work journal
which shocked us beyond
any level of being shocked at which
point we knew you know
something really bad is going on here
yeah little did you know where we'd be
you know just two years later because it
all seems to have burst forth
in a much more perverse way so to get to
where we started for a second when i
said to you oh you're gonna find common
cause with some of the conservatives and
it's gonna be a little scary and all
that
can you just tell people because i think
for people that maybe only know
some ancillary little thing about you
you well i don't want to put any words
in your mouth but you were sort of you
used to be just
like sort of a nominal liberal something
like that like you're not
you're not a political radical in any
way that's the irony
yeah i'm i'm not in fact i still
describe myself on twitter
to many people's chagrin so it's a
little troll going on there too
as a political i don't actually find
politics that interesting
i mean i don't really care what joe
biden's up to i just don't find
like oh democrats said this republicans
i don't find it interesting
so in that regard i really am a
political i definitely
you know kind of morally and politic
like policy-wise
and tilted to the left i'm largely
not in like the the strict sense that
you would see
from the libertarian party but i'm
largely libertarian i just want people
to do what they want to do
leave people alone for the most part and
let's try to organize a society that
kind of works
around that as a basic principle and so
i've never really been
terribly radical i did lean left for
sure
and i was always a little bit annoyed
with conservatism overall
i don't think i i don't i still don't
think i am conservative
in the older meaning of the word um
i'm definitely not you know if you went
and read some
particular you know political treatise
on conservatism i'm going to disagree
with quite a bit of it
at the same time i find a lot of
sympathy for
the arguments of preserving something
that is worth
preserving or conserving that so yeah i
was definitely not a radical definitely
kind of
middle of the road average every day
liberal left kind of guy and
i was i was genuinely like you said
apprehensive it's a kind of an
understatement to work with
conservatives in a significant regard
which has been really an interesting
experience because they're exactly the
opposite of what the leftist propaganda
had told me they would be like all right
okay so let's so let's do that then
because
flash forward a couple years and
suddenly i believe it was
last december so december 2020 it was
the one speaking gig
i did in all of 2020 public speaking at
least in front of a crowd i probably
same for you i bumped into you at
turning point usa
uh this is obviously charlie kirk's
event it's it's a
in essence a well it's a conservative
movement obviously but it's very linked
to well-known republicans and all that
and that's where i was like ah james
look at this look at you
two three years later what what have you
found
as you've talked about critical race
theory as you've exposed this stuff
what have you found each side has sort
of shown you
well the left is either
delusional about what's going on or
lying there's
no other way to put it they they claim
that people haven't the people that
criticize critical race theory for
example haven't read it
so that's the new thing as we're taping
this today it's the number one trend on
twitter right now
and it's because people like joy reid
from msnbc are saying
nobody even that criticizes uh crt
even has any understanding of what it is
that seems to be the big movie even
though i'm seeing plenty of people
explain it over and over again
yeah i don't think they've read it or if
they have read it they've read it with
kind of these rose-colored glasses or
without an
understanding of what the specialized
language actually means
you know you order you read a word like
democracy and you think it means
something oh i know what democracy means
but if you don't understand that in a
liberationist paradigm that it's not
possible to have a true democracy till
everybody is equal in other words until
communism
is achieved it's a loaded word so they
don't understand that a lot of the words
in these things are loaded
and they were intentionally loaded the
right however has been
a bit um facile and it's
analysis of critical race theory so it's
been very helpful you know or very good
for me to be able to help them
understand it
at a deeper level because for them
they've just been saying socialism
and while that's some percentage
truth 20 something maybe percent i don't
know how to qualify those things
it's not the whole story it's not the
whole story by any stretch
um and they have however been very
receptive to trying to understand more
about it
they've been very curious about it they
perceive that something is wrong and and
don't have the vocabulary
to comprehend what that is whereas what
i perceive from people on the left
is that they don't want the vocabulary
to comprehend it's almost like they want
their head
if they're good decent everyday liberals
not activists it's like they want their
head
in the sand to not comprehend what's
going on
and so they constantly get blindsided
it's like i watched some of these people
on twitter the kind of
you know left country club very smart
people i call them uh it's like watching
them step on a rake over and over and
over again it's like whacks them in the
face and they're like
you know why are there these rakes here
whack and they do it again and it whacks
them in the face and like everybody
should be nicer
whack and it hits them in the face again
i think it's very
it is it's really it's really horrific
um
so i feel like there's this very deep
you know desire to learn more
and get it accurate among most
conservatives whereas others are just
kind of like
no it's socialism the end and then on
the left there's just straight
either delusional ignorance or lying
about it which is
shocking has that changed your feelings
on
what a liberal is in a way because to me
it exposed a fatal flaw in liberalism
that i did not want to see
it doesn't change for me what a liberal
is in the kind of classical
philosophical liberal sense what it
changes for me is people who identify as
the liberal label
have they're largely a country club they
are largely
almost at this point a cult that want to
believe
and have a social identity baked into
being left of center
to where upholding that social identity
becomes much more important than the
truth so when you talk about actual
classical liberalism
based on enlightenment rationalism the
truth is supposed to be the north star
for almost everything and so they have
diverged and it literally is a country
club mentality or a social identity
mentality
that has captured an enormous swath of
that population to the point where it's
like i've had conversations with family
members
and they say things like oh well i
really like what that ron desantis says
but he's a republican so i could never
vote for him
and is that's the entirety of the
analysis is they don't want to look
bad to their oh this is we only ever
vote democrat friends or whatever and
it's
that is disgusting that's something i
never would have identified with or
respected even in somebody even several
years ago when we were having that
conversation
right well and it's and it's
anti-liberal it's anti-like
it's anti-reason right that's the point
so
so as you then were talking about this
publicly then you start getting invited
to these turning point things and
on to other uh let's say conservative
leaning shows
and then you go on and you i've been
i've watched enough interviews you talk
about being an atheist you talk about
some of the differences you have as
you're unpacking all the crt stuff
and it seems to me nobody cares which is
very much my experience
no i actually end up having really
interesting conversations with people
who want to learn more about my
perspective
if i were trying to be subversive which
i have no real interest in doing
but it's much more effective to be
making friends and coming in in good
faith rather than just attacking because
they actually want to hear my
perspective oh i'll think about that
rather than you know
shut up lived hard you know it's been a
very different experience i've had
nothing but a very welcoming friendly
kind
interested experience as i go along
because i'm trying to offer them
something that
is of value to speaking vocabulary into
their experience that they
they know something's wrong they don't
know what and i found nothing but
acceptance actually i mean what a big
red pill experience for me i went to
cpac in 2020 you know
so obviously let me get my devil horns
out but i went to cpac and i didn't know
what to expect i didn't really want to
go but i was in dc
and i thought you know let's pop over
for a day
see what's going on i went one day just
for the afternoon i didn't make a big
deal of it i wasn't part of the
conference
just wanted to walk around and see and i
expected you know i was going to walk
from leftist indoctrination
i expected i was going to walk into like
the whitest room in the world and all of
you know all of these things that
they've said and it
wasn't that and before that i went to
this big conservative
uh christian conference and i expected
again and it wasn't that
you know expected all of this kind of
like you know hate against the libs and
you get a little bit of that at cpac but
you know hate against this and it's
going to be super white and it's going
to be anti-gay and it's going to be this
and that
and it just wasn't it was just people
coming together
getting to know each one of one another
and the the amount of actual
individualism that each person is who
they are bringing what they're bringing
to the table
was the thing that's shown through the
most and i was just shocked i mean i
went home and i had to like just think
about this i was like this doesn't make
sense it doesn't match what i was told
about these evil conservatives these
so-called evil conservatives
and then that's you know once you start
realizing how much you're being lied to
bricks start falling out of the wall
real fast right you start seeing it
everywhere you see a little bit of it
and then there is no
there's no middle ground then you just
kind of see the lies absolutely
everywhere
what about on the religious side because
i know for a lot of my
liberal friends those very smart people
as you call them uh whoever will still
talk to crazy guys like us
um one of the they seem to have two
things that that just fully
stop them from shifting into what i
would say is a more cohesive reality
one is abortion and the other is belief
the abortion one we could if you want to
go into it we can but i think
we don't have to do that much political
stuff but the belief one
i think is really interesting because
you go into these conferences
and suddenly you have you're being
invited by christians
by believers and here they have an
atheist telling them about the thing
that's
in essence destroying their church and
that's the that's the reason right
there's this thing destroying their
church and i remember the first couple
of times i got invited to these
you know i was hesitant i didn't know
what i was going to step into
and what i found were people who it was
i don't want to put myself on too high
of a of a pedestal here but it was
almost like
i was their doctor and they're saying
you know our church has cancer what's
happening
can you tell me what's happening here
and i sat down with some some actual
fairly significant leaders of faith
you know in private settings both
private and public settings
and just talked them through you know
this is what it is this is what and
again
that very welcoming like we we brought
food for you come to our house
my wife's making food we're going to
have a dinner together
you know and i thought this is very
interesting i'm of course going to be
respectful i'm not going gonna
like go into like a full like atheist
tick
and just start arguing with them when
they've invited me and we're not
that's not the purpose so then i was
like you know what they're gonna they
bring their faith into everything
so it's like i'm just gonna listen to
them about their faith
i'm just going to talk to them like i'm
not going to just
pretend i'm going to be who i am but i
want to listen to them and understand
the world they way they understand the
world
like okay you know articulate this for
me what does faith
see within critical race theory what
does what does it see about the
brotherhood of man what does it see
about
imago dei let's talk about these things
and i just had some very prominent
people
of faith both catholic i think we're
both friends with bishop baron now
uh and and protestant just lay it out
for me and
instead of arguing when they say some
faith-based things like well i'll listen
what a what a radical concept right and
i was like well this is
i don't agree with all of the
presuppositions behind this but this is
a
way to understand the world and as a
matter of fact it's a good way
to make sense of a lot of things in the
world and so i feel like it's actually
deeply enriched my understanding of
people of each other of humanity but
also of the issues that we're facing in
the world right now and what it takes to
stand up to them and
what it takes to find what it you know
what is it inside of you the moral fiber
inside of you
that you have to have to be able to
resist a ultimately communist
demoralization
and has this changed your feelings about
belief in any way
for you personally i'm much warmer to
the idea of people believing it hasn't
changed my belief
i very much like to draw off of the
lessons i love to sit and listen to
pastors or priests speak and tell the
lessons
that they draw from their scripture or
from the philosophy around their
scripture or from the history
i think there's a lot of depth and value
there i'm very interested in hearing it
i
still would be in the you know great
repository of wisdom
but not literally true category um
but it's been very enriching as another
perspective
another way for me to look at the same
questions that we all kind of grapple
with in life
uh and i i feel like it hasn't changed
my belief underlying i'm still an
atheist but
it's been i think enormously enriching
to how i think about the problems of of
navigating life
in society and and you know interacting
with one another
so i think but correct me if i'm wrong
you came up with the term
crypto woke related to these was that
yours originally
yeah as far as i know yeah basically
these people that like
kind of get it but then they refuse to
do
all the measures to defend themselves
against it which is sort of what you're
describing of the of the modern liberal
let's say
um can you just unpack that a little bit
more because i think if we can if we can
break
those guys whoever is left that that
could be the key here
yeah i think it is whatever is left in
the middle sure
and this is the thing i realized right
before the election
i got invited to do a long podcast
episode with brett weinstein and jesse
single
and to talk about and we were going to
represent three positions in the
election
brett was going to vote neither of the
two major parties
i had decided and declared that i was
going to vote for trump and jesse of
course was going to vote for biden
we were going to hash out our
differences in what he called a unity
campfire
and in the process of listening to jesse
defend his desire
to vote for biden over the course of a
couple or three hours
i realized that these people that are
rationalizing
woke ideology are a major problem now
crypto woke is a
pretty stinging term so i don't really
want to apply that as in judiciously
as sometimes the fray on twitter implies
crypto woke would actually
imply that they are faking it um i don't
think for example that jesse is faking
his beliefs i think he's just
to be clear for people that don't he's a
writer for new york magazine
or yeah something new york magazine or
new yorker i get confused between these
things frequently new york magazine i
think
he's got a book he's he's a i've had
dinner with him he's a genuinely nice
guy
to spend time with as far as i can tell
but he just doesn't get it
and he's quite vicious on social media
well i was gonna say he said some
absolutely horrible things about me i've
never engaged with him other than to
call him out on the things that he's
called me i'm just putting that out
there
having this conversation with him no so
yeah um
and i realized these people who are
rationalizing this
are the cr what they called the useful
idiots
back in soviet times are the people
who are they they they
what's the right word it's not whitewash
is the word i want to use
but they make it they make this very
radical ideology
seem safe and acceptable to normal
people who
read outlets like new york magazine or
the new york times or the atlantic
and they i don't some do it probably
willfully and they are genuinely crypto
woke
and then other people do it just not
realizing they i think the mentality
is and i have heard this from them many
times is they can't really mean
what it actually says i can read to them
a piece you know critical race theory
calls into question
the very foundations of the liberal
order including equality theory
legal reasoning enlightenment
rationalism and the neutral principles
of constitutional law
and they seize on well it just calls it
into question it can't really mean that
they want to undo those things
they just call it into question and then
you know i say you know another quote
that quote by the way is in the first
paragraph of critical race theory and
introduction
another quote from that book is you know
critical race theorists are highly
suspicious of a number
another liberal mainstay namely rights
highly suspicious of rights and they say
ah they're just highly suspicious of
there's ways that rights can go wrong
you know by focusing on rights you
actually can kind of screw people over
like somebody could say something really
hurtful i could say something really
rude to you
and then i you could shoot back at me
man that was wrong why'd you say that i
could say free speech
i have a right you know and so they're
gonna seize upon oh
they're not against rights they're just
highly suspicious of them
and it's like come on guys like look at
the fruit in practice there's
there's a you know speaking into the
faith what you learn from
listening to people of faith and how
they conceptualize the world look at the
fruit that the tree is bearing this is a
bad tree it is bearing bad fruit and if
you go and read the texts
yeah you can you can whitewash this down
or maybe the word is red wash
this down to where it's pretty milk
toast or whatever but it
it's genuinely quite radical and then
they don't have explanations for things
like maybe equity is not enough
we need a revolution that's rochelle
gutierrez i'm not making these things up
by the way
um so that i figured was the problem so
i started calling them out
starting in october of last year i
turned my main gun from the woke who
i think are a huge problem and started
aiming at the people who are
largely making it seem more socially
acceptable than it is
they're they're laundering that's right
that's it yeah they're laundering these
ideas but in a different way they're not
doing you know what we call ideal
laundering before which is to
get them into socially acceptable
publications
like academic journals but they're doing
a different duty
they're they're literally making them
seem no no there's this really
reasonable interpretation
where if you absolutely pretend it
couldn't happen here
then that must be what they really mean
these people must be more reasonable
than they are and i feel like it's
with the ones who are unintentionally
crypto woke
i feel as though they lack the capacity
to believe
that there are people out there who
genuinely think outside of the
broadly liberal classical liberal
paradigm and who genuinely want to
subvert
or uh overthrow that paradigm for
something different
that they control that's truly
totalitarian
okay so since the number one trend right
now
is critical race theory and the idea
here is that oh
the critics of it can't even define it
james i think i asked you to do this
once before but now i will give you the
perfect opportunity
i've got two minutes and 20 seconds on a
twitter video
what is critical race theory i don't
need two minutes and 20 seconds anymore
critical race theory
is the belief that the fundamental
organizing principle of society
is racism namely systemic racism as they
call it
which is what you call
the cause otherwise unknown unspecified
cause for when there are differences in
outcomes where white people come out
ahead of some people of color sometimes
and systemic racism hides itself better
so critical race theory believes
to add on to this definition the
definition is racism is the organizing
principle of society the belief that
that
but to add on to that they believe that
when you tackle racism it doesn't
improve you can't actually get
over racism it's very tricky under a
doctrine called interest convergence
that leads it to hide itself better to
put a better mask on
to cover itself up better and so racism
doesn't get better over time it actually
is permanent and becomes
worse because it's more insidious it's
more hidden and critical race theory is
the tool
they use to uncover that hidden racism
that is present in
all features of society because it is
the fundamental organizing principle
of all social phenomena i hate to
guess that i know the answer to this
question but since joy reid is asking
people
publicly on twitter can any of the
critical race theory
uh critics come on my show uh have you
tried to get on to any of these shows
have they invited you on any of these
shows and would you
not try shows but
i would go i've certainly not been
invited i don't know if you've noticed
on twitter that people keep
saying like joyride i think i even used
her earlier on twitter
um they post nobody blah blah can define
it and then i just post a
a gif of a stealth bomber
that's me i'm the stealth bomber right
like they don't pay attention to me they
try to pretend i don't exist
maybe it's because they don't know who i
am and maybe it's because they
know good and damn well i can do it well
not only you but also
uh carlin borsenko she immediately
responded to joy reid and said exactly
what it was she laid it out beautifully
chris ruffo responded i mean it's not
that nobody's i've had enough shows on
this that it's not that nobody is
responding
what about the other part of it where it
is prescribing
things that we've all fundamentally
believed
were good like being on time and hard
work
and knowing empirical truths like two
plus two equals four
that suddenly those things are thought
of through the critical ace
race lens as white supremacist
tools i mean if that's what a white
supremacist is showing up
to work on time working hard caring
about truth
i i get some white supremacists yeah i
know they've included things like
loyalty and all kind i mean like
basically every single virtue virtue
that upholds society
because they are utterly convinced that
the society that we
currently occupy which is broadly we
could say a classically liberal republic
is was founded by people who are white
supremacists and they founded it with
this is a conspiracy theory by the way
they founded it with the intent to
maintain
white supremacy forever and so
everything that they valued everything
that thomas jefferson valued
everything that george washington valued
everything that thomas paine valued
everything that john locke valued
everything that
isaac newton valued and he's even kind
of pre-enlightenment in a sense
all of these they really hate newton
though all of these people
were actually trying to establish white
supremacy as the
dominant orthodoxy for the rest of time
and
that's literally a conspiracy theory um
i don't know what in the world i mean
the
books are they have a book charles mills
has a book 1997 or something like this
called the racial contract
that says that all white people are
secretly involved in a racial contract
and we all assent to it although nobody
ever actually talks about it or tells
anybody about it
that we're going to keep white people up
and keep people of color especially
black people down
do you sometimes admire it for sort of
like the conspiracy
behind it like how sort of it all
encompassing it came to people you know
we played the clip i know you saw it too
we played the clip of mark lamont hill's
show and chris ruffo is on
and mark lamont hill lays out a question
that just on its face makes no sense
he's saying to rufo
well tell me what you think about being
white is why
being white is so great and that's not
ruffo's
intention his intention is not to be
racist but it's like
even in roofo's answer which was quite
good you could see there was
there was literally no nugget of truth
that lamont hill was going to be willing
to
accept yeah i mean the
it's it's like a highly evolved virus
frankly and then the sense of like
that's why i keep comparing it to alien
it's alien you got to admire it yeah
it's like yeah stepping back and looking
at it from that
perspective it's like wow it's really
figured out if in the virus metaphor
which i use liberally because they have
a paper called women's studies as a
virus they published in 2016 where they
say that the ideal way to think of
themselves is as
a virus for instance hiv ebola and sars
those are the ones they name
or a virus that causes cancer because
cancer represents true transformational
change so therefore cancer good
where cancer that's their that's their
argument if you look at it from that
though
to see how it's exploited the receptor
sites
of liberal society but also even
you know like religion and conservative
society like that's going to latch onto
that kindness that respect that charity
it's going to force you to be kind but
then when you say well you need to be
kind in return they say
you're forcing me to participate in your
regime right
and the way that it's been so successful
at latching onto those receptors like oh
i want to hear your argument give me
your best argument let me hear you
out and then the second you turn around
they say oh your argument is based on
trying to maintain your privilege
you know there's something you know from
the virologist's perspective
perversely beautiful to behold in this
but
um this is a matter of great interest i
think for psychologists and
to start sorting out over the coming
decades if we we survived this as a
civilization
it's hard to respect in the kind of
direct sense though because it's
patently evil
it's blatantly racist it's blatantly
destructive
it has nothing to build look at for
example the brand equity of harvard
university i just saw the article in the
wall street journal
that said i won't hire ivy leaguers
anymore which i predicted by the way in
a conversation with yalies
a few months ago i was like it's only a
matter of time i wouldn't hire an ivy
leaguer right now
i wouldn't either and i would hesitate
to hire a college grad
and it's like that's the next step
that's where it's going it burns through
brand equity it
burns through real equity so quickly
that it because it can't build it has
nothing to build
there's nothing to respect in that do
you think a guy like bernie sanders
who i don't know what he truly thinks
about critical race theory i mean he'll
constantly tell you america
is is racist and all of that kind of
stuff i don't know what he really thinks
in terms of that specifically but do you
think he realizes what he helped usher
in
like the average progressive i would put
him at the spear of like the
the radical movement do you think he
realized what was going to come behind
him or that it is going to destroy him
one day
i don't think so i don't think that they
have any realization
um that they actually played a
significant role
in bringing in this thing which has
largely already marginalized him i mean
with
bernie he's been co-opted he was
certainly not an identity politics guy
in 2016 and then all of a sudden he's
like a raging identity politics guy like
something changed
um a lot of my friends who were big
bernie supporters
uh were very much against identity
politics and then they were
through the years of trump that you know
they brainwashed these people
trumps are racist trump's a sexist blah
blah so if you
you know don't come on board with the
identity politics you
probably are somehow a trumper and
therefore you know you sympathize with
trump
ideology or whatever and they were very
successful at this and so what i i don't
think they're able to accept
their own involvement in what has
occurred
because they see themselves as having
having been against it
and then some greater evil i think came
into the world that they
trump of course the greatest evil of all
all orange menaces and they've ever been
and they have to i seriously i think
they cook their noodles man i don't
think that they're seeing things
straight because the orange man bat is
just such
a center it's like a it's like not a
black hole but like an orange hole
it just bends all the light rays around
it and they can't see straight
right right that's like interstellar you
can't see on the other side of it kind
of thing because it's sucking the light
[Music]
what else what should the average person
know
like like for the average person that
doesn't want to fight about this all day
but
what do you think the average person can
do because that seems to me is the
answer and we're seeing more and more of
it by the way every day now
there's a viral video of a mother at a
conference fighting the teachers
fighting the administration's i don't
want to teach my children to be racist i
don't want to teach my children
that they're bad because they're white
or i just saw one this morning of a
black mother saying i don't want to
teach my children that they're damaged
because they're black
all things that a sane person would
agree with what do you think can be done
for the average person
or by the end yeah the average person
has to realize what i started to say
very vigorously last summer and i was of
course resoundingly mocked for this
this isn't going to blow over we're
either going to push it
out of power or it's not going to get
out it's going to continue
we there is no letting it blow over it's
not going to blow over
it so you have to decide what you want
to do with that
not everybody is going to be the person
who stands up and
speaks at their their school board but
you can be the person who makes that
person dinner
you know not everybody is going to be
the face not everybody's going to take
the risk
but you can be the person who offers
moral support who you know
creates a network but the most important
thing then for people to realize
is this is a lesson that i learned
watching people stand up to
absurd covet policy is that courage
begets courage
and cowardice begets cowardice it's a
two-sided street
or two-sided coin when you see so
there's this video it went around i
don't know if i could find it again
easily on twitter
and i think it's in canada but maybe it
wasn't there's a bakery or a shop or
something and you know the health
inspector comes in and
or whatever the covid cops come in and
they're hassling them and finally this
one guy says
you're trespassing you need to go and
everybody's kind of cowering and then
second one guy spoke up the whole crowd
starts yelling you gotta go you gotta go
you gotta go
and they ended up you know leaving and
it was it's the most blatant
demonstration i've ever seen that some
nobody's speaking up everybody kind of
shied everybody's getting kind of
bullied around
the second one person spoke up a crowd
erupted and that's one other
thing if you're afraid to be the person
who's going to inspire the courage that
begets courage
i jumped off a cliff man you jumped off
a cliff
we didn't know where we were going to
land right now if you jump off
the edge it's not a cliff it's a stage
and there are hands ready to carry you
yes right and people need to understand
that the ground swell against critical
race areas
the biggest trend on twitter right now
as we were just saying a minute ago as
the time of the taping
it's huge it is a hot issue it's
85 95 depending on where you are red or
blue
issue for most people in most
jurisdictions right now of
get this crap out of our schools so the
you have every reason in the world to be
courageous and you're courageous is
going to be infected
infectious on the other hand if you're a
coward
other people see your cowardice and
either somebody's going to step up and
be courageous
instead of you and you get no you you
did nothing respectable
or it's just going to encourage more
people to stay silent more people to
keep their head down more people
to hope oh maybe it'll blow over and i
don't have to take a risk
um but that's not what's going to happen
it's either going to get pushed out
or it's it's going to kill us jump
it's all people can do so actually
speaking of jumping when you jump and
then suddenly you are
you're out there and you're taking you
know what are thought of on
as unpopular positions however true as
they may be
you're going to get mobbed and one of
the interesting things was a few months
ago
you were trying to explain to people
that
critical race theory was going to be
incredibly destructive
and perhaps the biggest threat to jews
in in modern
times um or in our times now let's say
since the holocaust something like that
uh you got then called an anti-semite
for that and there has been a ton of
people calling you i i've defended you
i'm
more than happy to defend you always on
this stuff and these are the same people
who call everyone else a nazi
can you explain a little bit about how
jews don't fit into that
calculator well and why you were warning
about this
well i mean there are multiple reasons i
was warning about it but i do think that
critical race theory poses
the greatest threat to jews in america
and throughout the west
maybe the whole world today certainly
we're not talking about 1930 whatever
uh certainly not that but the greatest
threat
now when we see people getting beat up
it posits that jews
and there's a book called how jews
became white folks by
um karen brodkin from the 90s 98 or
something like this
and she lays out that jewish people were
not considered white when they came to
america
you know largely following the holocaust
for example they were discriminated
against they were ghettoized etc
and then they worked very diligently to
become recognized as white often
throwing
black people and other people of color
under the bus which is not historically
accurate
they often tended to be progressive and
integral in civil rights movements in
many regards and so they position
themselves
and she actually makes this argument not
just as white to gain access to white
privilege
but as the setters of whiteness the
people who are the highest level of
white culture who get to be the cultural
yeah the people who create white culture
and define white culture
so they literally become the people at
the very top of white
culture and then they hoard the
resources for themselves and this is a
literal recreation of anti-semitism
and the thing is what i was warning
about is this is its own
serious danger far left anti-semitism is
on the rise it's going to continue to be
on the rise
i said there's a normal baseline which
apparently i got accused of that like
apparently i was normalizing it they
said i was just trying to express in a
tweet that anti-semitism already exists
now there's more coming from the far
left but i said there's also more coming
from the far right because many
progressive jews are actually touting
this ideology
and then for for me who ties it to his
historical roots for example in the
frankfurt school
uh of critical theory which is correct
to tie it to that
those guys were all jews the so-called
cultural marxism conspiracy theory
that's a wikipedia entry now there is no
cultural marxism explained there
there's just a conspiracy theory is that
oh these frankfurt school jews
wanted to overturn western civilization
and that's a conspiracy theory it's
anti-semitic
so i said there are people and somebody
criticizes that a lot people come to me
all the time and they're like james just
admit that it is actually jews
i'm like no it's communists and they're
like just just take the last step
so all these actual anti-semites are
always trying to get me to go that far
and i said and i've had some very scary
conversations with some
from far right characters not not nazis
but like
kind of mainstream dudes who are getting
more and more seduced and i said there's
going to be a rising or there is a
rising
far-right anti-semitism that's new from
that normal baseline
and by the way by the way your the point
that you're making there's also
something that dennis prager has been
arguing
for years and years and years that that
these people who traded in
all their beliefs as jews for
progressivism
leftism socialism communist everything
else they're not doing it in the name of
judaism they're doing it in the name of
that ideology exactly and the problem is
as reactionaries often tend to be
they're not real precise
so they see a bunch of jews taking up
communism and they're like ah communism
is jewish
is jewish just take the last step and
i'm like guys this is a disaster in the
making
this is a tidal wave of hate for jews
from both sides
from the fringes of both sides that's on
the rise
rapidly on the rise and i warned about
this and then
um some important blue czech people
immediately accused me of blaming jews
for anti-semitism
which is a one of these third rail
things that you're not allowed to touch
and i was
like well i'm going to continue to point
out this problem because
we're headed to a catastrophe uh
when we see what's happened over the
last couple months so okay so there were
the attacks on the jews in new york and
la and
all over the place but then also what
was preceding that was
all of these attacks that unfortunately
were done
almost exclusively by black people on
asian people so it was very confusing
for the intersectional calculator
and very confusing for mainstream media
but
so all of the messaging out there was oh
we should we stand with our asian
brothers and sisters which i don't want
anyone to have any hate crimes
against them of course but they could
never really say who was doing it
and now there's some videos leaking out
where we are seeing black people attack
asian people
and then there was one video just in the
last little while where the guy said
well
you're the oppressive class i can't be
racist towards you you're asian i'm
black i can't
that is critical race theory that's
literally in the in the docks that
you're referring to
yeah that's exactly right so yeah asians
are in jews also when they're not
considered white
directly asians are often considered
white adjacent they're said to have
taken up the values of whiteness
and these hard work and you know
punctuality and loyalty and all of these
different things they've taken up these
values
and therefore they're complicit in the
maintenance of the oppressive white
supremacist system even though they're
not so now they're seen not just
as uh people who are upholding the
system but also traitors to the
solidarity of racial oppression that the
theory
posits and so you add in that to the
fact that oh this
oppressive system is screwing you over
if you're black you have no
opportunity because the oppressors you
know i don't know if they think that
black people can't
read but they go you know they can and
they go and read and they say oh
joe biden means they can't open
computers or something that's
yeah joe i don't know joe malarkey i
said that on tv accidentally
um whoops um no but it's
they go look and they say you know well
all the opportunities in education are
being stolen
because of whiteness and they're
excluding black people and they're
stealing it from black people
and then go look at the statistics and
see these advanced high schools or
70 percent asian and it's like it's not
that hard to figure out who you're going
to get jealous and mad at
right and then when you add in the fact
that you have economically depressed and
stress and the covet and the
crime and everything else is rising and
all these stresses are rising
mentally ill and criminal people are
being like just let off in these
democrat cities it's only a matter of
time you're going to start seeing
violence
and that violence is going to happen
along predictable pathways where there's
scapegoating
and so you know whiteness asian you're
having your opportunity stolen from you
well who's dealing with the school 70
percent asian well it's probably the
chinese let's get them
you know it's not hard logic speaking of
the chinese do you think
uh not the chinese people but the china
the government of china do you think
that it is somehow complicit
in uh spreading this stuff in the united
states it seems to me that if you wanted
to win a war against the united states
you're probably not doing it with nukes
and troops on the ground right we're not
going to suffer a ground invasion
but that in essence we will just do it
to ourselves and you won't need one
bullet fired
or or perhaps russia or something else
well it's certainly the case the chinese
understand the dynamics of a cultural
revolution
um that's undeniable but the the direct
answer to your question is has to be yes
i don't think it's always been that way
or even necessarily for long been that
way they used to make fun of the by so
the white left
and then they stopped making fun of them
and then all of a sudden you see this
summit you know this diplomatic summit
in in alaska
and what are the chinese hitting our our
american diplomats with and they have no
defenses to it's oh well you guys are
systemically racist and what do you see
there
you know their propaganda accounts on
social media constantly hammering oh you
guys are systemically racist we're not
going to listen to the
to the west because there's no to
america because there's no moral
authority because of its systemic racism
problem until they fix it
meanwhile of course very famously they
have like commercials where the chinese
girls washing the black guy
asian in the washing machine with soap
you know it's like they're not
exactly great on that issue themselves
so
certainly they're aware of it certainly
they are fueling it certainly they
have been throwing money at things that
have gone down this path
and certainly they would understand that
it will weaken america from within the
strategy broadly speaking is what's
known as top down bottom up
inside outside so if they can infiltrate
on the inside and weaken something from
the inside outside
pressure can then crush it so that's
that aspect of it and they would
understand political warfare and these
strategies extremely well
i mean they wrote there suza wrote the
book on this stuff
2000 years ago or something yeah all
right last question for you you've
you've given me the okay you got to jump
and there's going to be some
some hands to catch you um
i mean just talk directly to the parent
that's watching this right now or the 16
year old kid who doesn't want to believe
he's evil because of the color of his
skin
or the teacher who is afraid of saying
what the truth i mean this has
infiltrated everything
the guy in hr the freaking plumber
feel free to talk directly to them i got
some bad news to start with and then
we'll get a little more encouraged
um you actually have to learn a little
bit about this your art you actually are
going to have to go read
at least a couple of pages of critical
race theory to defeat that argument
that we hear from joy read or whatever
the people criticizing it don't know
what it is
luckily if you start with some of the
basics it's not that hard you have to
get the gist
now the bad news is over you do have to
become an educated and informed
that said you're not racist they are
they don't have the argument you do the
evidence is not on their side it's on
yours
so they don't have the evidence they
don't have the argument they don't have
the moral high ground
you do have all three you have the
evidence if you go look
where they're implementing these
diversity programs companies and schools
are doing
worse the evidence racism is on the rise
we see these problems arising in our
cities being justified along the lines
of these
doctrines you have the evidence you have
the argument it's not hard to see
through how their argument is actually
completely bogus that
oh we're going to overcome racism by
putting more social significance into
race
and intentionally making the white race
a negative thing and applying this
uh imposition of racial identity on
everybody in this kind of very
um politically active way and turning
everybody into political activists
instead of you know educated
uh informed active interactive citizens
and then you also have the moral high
ground if they are injecting racism into
everything
if they are the the people who want to
tear things down
you're not in them they try to frame you
out as a white supremacist or a
sympathizer or as a racist or whatever
it's not you it's actually them so you
have the evidence you have the argument
you have the moral high ground don't be
afraid get a little bit of informed
get together with some of your friends
your your other parents at the school
what
you talk to your kids engage with them
engage with them on these ideas ask them
to talk about it
and then show up show up and cheer if
you don't want to talk
show up and and you know find out who is
talking and make them cookies
something like that get involved in some
way start getting organized you can do
it
it's all on your side james you have
truly been an all-star in this thing
and if anyone wants to support you or
find out more about your work
or bake you some cookies or whatever
else it might be they can go to
newdiscourses.locals.com where you own
all your stuff my friend
i don't know i do you own it absolutely
crazy
james continued good luck i i look
forward to seeing you in real life one
of these days
yeah thanks dave if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about academia instead of non-stop
yelling check out our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell